my talk of the table is about a chat
with oprah about the death of queen
elizabeth as you know oprah sat down
with prince harry and meghan markle in a
very revealing interview last year and
made a lot of news while i was in
toronto this past weekend uh doing a
story with oprah about sidney it's a
documentary at the toronto film fest
more on that a little bit later on but
of course the conversation about the
queen came up and i asked her about her
thoughts about that and because every
time i see a story about oprah harry and
megan it's bombshell interview bombshell
interview so i wanted to know what do
you think about the characterization
oprah about bombshell interview
i was as surprised by the bombshell as
everybody else i was doing an interview
to
offer them a platform
to tell their story about why they left
and that was my number one intention was
just clarity on why did you leave and so
some of the things that were revealed in
that interview
came as a surprise to me
and those surprises are now referred to
as bombshell but i didn't set out to do
a bombshell interview i set out to do
uh an interview have a conversation that
would allow them to tell their story
and now people say reconciliation
reconciliation we hope the brothers
reconcile what do you say i do not get
into people's family matters and i
certain you know everybody
who
has
experienced some challenges in their
families with in-laws or brothers or
sisters knows how difficult some of
those situations can be
and i'm sure that you know for the royal
family it's no different and
nobody consults me about their family
business so i try to stay out of
people's family business
and after that oprah goes and gayle that
is the end of this interview
so we were there because we were as as i
said oprah produced a documentary on um
sidney poitier so we had interviewed
oprah who's a producer reggie hudlin the
director and three of the poor daughters
so that's the reason why we're there she
didn't say you know i'd like to sit down
and talk about harry and megan in the
royals because that's the last thing she
wanted to do but i did say to her you
know you've never met the queen what are
your thoughts she goes actually i did
meet the queen at harry and megan's
wedding i totally forgot about this
she's standing in line to meet the queen
and she sort of stumbled and bumbled a
bit trying to curtsy to not curtsy and
they had a very brief exchange so she
has actually met the queen wow
that's why i said wow you did meet her
only oprah would meet such an echelon of
stars on a regular basis that she'd be
like i forgot to mention i
meant that i forgot to answer that it
was interesting yeah but you're right it
was a bombshell interview that's for
sure that's that's that's not how she
characterizes it right you're right but
it was though that's happened the way it
was recently turned out